good morning Sydney
and welcome to NDC Sydney 2018 my name
is Dylan BT and I'm gonna open the
conference today by talking to you about
apps algorithms and abstractions this is
me I am CTO at a company in London
called skills matter I have been
building website since 1992 I'm so old I
remember when webmasters walked the
earth I'm a Microsoft MVP
I run a user group in London I'm on the
Internet I am on Twitter I didn't always
look like this I was born in Kenya in
Africa in 1978 and shortly after I was
born
my father wanted to send a picture of me
to my grandparents who were living in
the UK so he took this photograph this
is me when I was a junior developer and
he took it using an old fashioned film
camera and took it to a pharmacy where
they developed it and he took that
picture he put it in an envelope and he
posted it
it took about probably six weeks and to
end for this picture to make it from
Kenya over to Oxfordshire in the United
Kingdom one photograph six weeks anyone
want to estimate the bandwidth of taking
six weeks to send a single photo we're
not talking broadband here we're talking
I think nano bits worth of bandwidth but
here today in 2018 things are a little
different
you
let's enjoy the conference I'll see you
next year within my lifetime we've gone
from this to this we've gone from six
weeks to send one photograph to being
able to send pictures to somebody on a
moving train being such a everyday
occurrence you know we all take that for
granted how many of you get that like
you know your partner just sends you
pictures of the cat or the kids or you
know and it doesn't need to be a big
deal when I was a kid if you had a baby
you'd send a picture around the world if
someone got married if somebody
graduated from university it was
important enough to send a picture
around the world and now we just do it
because the cats being kind of derpy you
know and what I want to do today
somebody asked me a little while ago
they're like how does it actually work
and I was like I have no idea I do not
actually understand 99% of the things
that make that experience possible so I
went away and I looked it up and that's
what I'm going to be talking to you
about today so you take your phone out
you have the little pinging noise you
take your phone out of your pocket and
you see this four bars of signal because
we're addicted to signal right here in
2018 what does that thing actually mean
you know how does a phone in your pocket
talk to the rest of the world wirelessly
and you're like well obviously the
answer is radio and it is radio is
pretty simple radio is one of those cool
things we didn't invent we just kind of
discovered it you take a piece of wire
and you put some electricity through it
and it emits electromagnetic radiation
I'm not going to tell you why this
happens that's just how our universe
happens to be wired but if you put
another piece of wire on the other side
of the room or on the other side of the
country you can get your electricity
back out because it picks up these waves
and it recreates the original signal now
this was the first of many many game
changes that were going to talk about in
this because as soon as people
discovered you could do this they
realized that we can encode sound as
electricity and then we can transmit
electricity wirelessly through the air
and radio broadcasting was born and
suddenly for the first time in history
you could actually talk to somebody who
wasn't standing in the same room as you
we could broadcast news we could
broadcast music we invented transistor
radio receivers which
never build one of those crystal radio
kits which has no battery it literally
takes energy straight out of the air and
turns it into a sick kind of crackly
signal that you can hear so that basic
principle has not really changed all
that much since the invention of radio
but as you can appreciate there is a
hell of a difference between the
handheld receiver on the left and the
handheld receiver on the right in this
picture and in order to make modern
cellular communication work they have us
off three problems first problem is the
strength of a radio signal is directly
proportional to how far you're sending
it yes certain amount of power you can
send a weak signal a really long way you
can send a shortwave radio signal
literally around the planet with one
transmitter but you can't include a
whole lot of information you know when
you're driving way out in the country
and all you can get AM radio stations AM
long distance small amount of power the
signal quality's not great you get into
the city FM radio sounds a lot better
they can do stereo we need kind of FM
plus we need really really high degree
of signal and the easiest way to do that
is to move everything closer together
which means either you have to get
everyone in a very small space or you
need to build a lot of transmitters and
this is what a cellular network is every
one of these transmitters
all over the Sydney area is covering a
couple of kilometres of city blocks so
you'll never that far away in really
dense areas like downtown that's
probably one of these every few hundred
meters so first of all your phone is
very close to the transmitters that it's
talking to so we can pack a lot of
signal in for a certain amount of power
the second problem they had to solve
radio is a broadcast mechanism but it
only works in one direction you can use
it picture it like a highway you can
send information in one direction you
can send information in the other
direction if you try to send in both
directions at the same time it doesn't
work so we started having to come up
with mechanisms to do what's called
duplexing sending information in two
directions at once one of the earliest
systems they came up with was a thing
they call time division duplexing it's
basically like saying imagine you've got
this this piece of road between two
cities and you make a rule we don't want
any more head-on collisions so we're
gonna say that during the day you can go
in one direction
and after dark you can go in the other
direction and a dusk and dawn nobody's
allowed to drive anywhere it's pretty
simple mechanism right and then you know
someone comes up with the bright idea
they're like this duplexing thing is
working pretty well but actually it's
kind of dumb having to wait until dusk
before I can go home from work you know
what if we just do it on every hour so
in one half of the hour you can go one
direction everything stops go in the
other direction and then some bright
spark goes well actually in one
direction we just got you know little
cars going the other direction we are
lots of heavy traffic why don't we
change the length of the time windows so
they say okay well we have a little
window every hour where traffic there's
one direction and the rest of the hour
everything goes in the other direction
now take the hour and go minutes seconds
milliseconds microseconds you get this
thing down to microsecond time slicing
this is how the 2g network works that's
still in use in some parts of the US and
they actually changed the length of
those windows so if you're streaming
Netflix on the train or over a cellular
network they'll tweak it so that you
send one packet going I'm still here and
then the rest of it is allocated to
downstream bandwidth you start sending a
big file or attaching an email they'll
flip the window so you have lots of
upstream bandwidth now this is a pretty
good system but it has all sorts of
headaches to do with having to
synchronize clocks and various things
and once you get into you know people
moving through different cells and stuff
it's very complicated so somebody came
up with the the genius idea why don't we
doesn't build another freeway yeah we'll
have two roads running in opposite
directions look at this and everyone
went yeah we could probably do that so
what they're actually doing is you're
running two separate radio conversations
on two separate frequencies at the same
time and then somebody want well if we
got two of them maybe we could have more
so when your phone gives you those four
little bars which say you've got a good
strong cellular signal what it's
actually doing is there are about 16
channels that are dedicated to your
phone how many people in here just take
your phone out look at it right now put
your hand up if you've got a strong
signal yep yep yep that is pretty much
everybody so every single one of you has
got 16 channels of radio spectrum for
your personal use in this building think
for one second about the hardware that's
in the the receiving tower up on the
roof of this building that makes that
possible
we take it for granted and when you only
have two buzzer signal like a stupid
thing doesn't work it's like I don't
know the miracle is temporarily just a
little bit less than it normally is but
what these 16 channels they can dedicate
all of them for different things it's
like having a freeway for the emergency
services and another one for the post
and another one for ambulances and one
for driving on we've got all these
dedicated channels just to allow these
cellular data experiences to work so the
other problem they had with radio is
anybody can stick an antenna in the air
and they can pick up the signal and they
can listen to it it would be up to
having their email broadcast to everyone
in that Sydney crater business district
because I know I wouldn't so the next
thing they did is like we got all these
16 channels now we need to encrypt the
whole lot using a very complicated
cipher which is a combination of the
IMEI code in your phone the code in your
SIM card the manufacturer a whole bunch
of contracts rotating keys and all this
stuff happens without us really having
to think about it so we have a radio
signal or 16 of them we can talk in both
directions the whole thing is secure
nobody can listen in to it how do we use
that to transmit digital information
developers of a certain age may find the
following sounds nostalgic
[Music]
that's what data sounds like if you
broadcast it over an audio signal and
there is this fascinating little kind of
dead end in history in the early 1980s
in a couple of places around the world
in London in Germany I think there was a
station in Poland that did this radio
stations broadcast computer games they
would pick a late-night slot where there
wasn't really anyone listening into the
radio and the deejay would you know play
a couple of records and then he tell all
the people who were listening in you
know get your your cassette recorder and
plug it into the radio and press record
and then for about 20 minutes they would
broadcast a game a computer game and the
idea was they broadcast this you record
it onto cassette and if you had a good
strong signal and if nothing went wrong
and if you didn't run out of tape and if
there was no interference you would
literally be one of the first people in
history to wirelessly download a
computer game from what it wasn't even
the internet you know it's as late-night
talk radio but you know this idea of
turning data into audio and then turning
audio into radio Canha has an upper
limit of how much information we can
encode into it what we need to come up
with is a much better way of putting
digital information into one of these
radio signals and we're gonna
demonstrate that now because we here in
this room are gonna be a transmitter so
what I want you to do all you is clap
okay what we got here we set up a
carrier wave now we're going to start
encoding some information so first thing
we're going to do when I shot one we're
gonna clap loud sorry
one now quiet zero zero one
zero all right this is not frequency
this is amplitude modulation so even
guess what's coming next so the next
thing we're gonna do we're gonna set up
the same carrier wave okay except this
time when I'll shot one we're gonna go
twice as fast you ready one zero one
zero this is frequency modulation we
speed up and slow down the signal that
would broadcasting and that's how we
communicate the ones in the zeros now
there is another one and if there's any
drummers in the room you'll get this and
if you're not a drummer that's made kind
of mess with your head a little bit
we're gonna do the same thing but now
when I shot one we're gonna clap off the
beat you ready one zero one zero and
this is called face modulation what we
do is we take the signal we don't make
it louder softer we don't make it faster
slow we make it earlier and later so we
have these three mechanisms now that we
can use to push a very simple basically
a number digital signal on a carrier
wave on a radio now give yourselves a
round of applause
this is interference right now
now let's visualize what some of the
stuff actually looks like so the
simplest possible carrier wave looks
like this it's just this very simple
sine wave and what we're gonna do is
we're gonna take points on that spectrum
on that circle and we're gonna say okay
if it's here it's a zero and then if
it's on the other side that's what we
call a 180 degrees out of phase we're
gonna use that as a one and now we can
transmit the stream of ones and zeros
and you can see the way on this you get
the waves in phase the waves out of
phase in phase out of phase now there is
a limit on a radio signal is something
called the symbol rate this is each of
these little vertical slices here is a
symbol and there is a limit to how many
symbols we can transmit in a given
period of time so if we want to get more
data into it
need more power all we need more radio
for channels now both of those things
are expensive or we want to come up with
a way of putting more information into
each of those symbols so what if this by
the way is binary shift phase Kings
their own one what if we decide we're
going to use for points around this
compass so we got in phase we got 180
out of phase and then we got two points
in the middle that gives us two bits for
each symbol and we can do the same thing
we can encode a digital stream with that
and you see here the wave starts to get
a little bit more complicated this is
what we call quadrant quadrature shift
phase King let's go again let's split it
down and break it into eight now we can
send three bits of data for every one of
those single points this being named by
radio engineers has the incredibly
catchy title of pi by four quadrature
phase-shift King brought to you by the
people who brought you microsoft visual
studio team system develops Enterprise
Edition let's go even further what if as
well as changing the phase we start
changing the amplitude as well at the
same time that lets us put sixteen
points on our symbol generator so now
we're gonna get this really complicated
looking waveform but every one of those
symbols now can include four bits so
we've quadrupled the bandwidth of our
system without having to invest in more
power or build more transmitters or
anything with just using the space that
we have got more effectively this is
sixteen quadrature amplitude modulation
and it gets bigger there is a thing
called 64 QAM which crashed my
JavaScript animator so I can't show you
this one and there's 256 quadrature
amplitude modulation which is what
digital cable TV systems use and all of
these are based on ways of getting more
bandwidth more signal out of the same
equipment and the same block of
frequencies because those things are a
finite resource you know there's a point
where we're going to run out and we're
gonna be able to do is use the spectrum
we already have more effectively so all
this complexity is going on behind the
scenes and when you get your phone out
your pocket you get this little
searching thing and then you get bang
for G these four bars of signal you're
on a fourth generation network inside
your phone there are hundreds of amazing
it's tiny tiny little discrete
components that are doing all this kind
of stuff and somewhere in your messaging
application there is a chunk of code
that looks kind of like this while true
check for messages and check for
messages here is it's an incantation
because underneath that check for
messages there is HTTP which is the
network protocol and there's TLS which
is the encryption protocol that keeps
the HTTP secure and that's running on
top of TCP which is a guaranteed
delivery mechanism and the amazing thing
is that TCP guarantees delivery and TCP
is built on top of IP which it doesn't
which absolutely blows my mind you know
and then underneath that we have the
physical link layer which ensures that
every packet gets from the this piece of
equipment to the next one and underneath
that we've got the 4G and the LTE
networks that make it possible and
underneath that we've got the entire
concept of cellular networking
underneath that we have radio it's
basically just magic it's easier to
pretend that it's magic you know we
don't need to understand the stuff to be
able to use it to do things so let's go
back to our code while true check for
messages and if message count is greater
than zero play the alert sound so how do
we get that sound into a phone so first
of all phones are digital computers are
digital we need to take moving air which
is what our ears pick up out of the out
of the ether we need to turn that into a
stream of numbers and if you capture a
wave file or an mp3 file and you zoom
right in and you look at it you'll see
that all we're actually doing is we're
measuring a whole bunch of points
because you can express audio as a
string of numbers all you're doing is
you are just sampling at certain
intervals how loud is the sound right
now that's literally all digital audio
sampling is so in this example here and
in in most examples what we're doing
you'll see two things written on the
back of say like a compact disc you'll
see 44.1 kilohertz 16-bit means 44,000
100 times per second that's the
kilohertz bit we are saying how loud is
it right now and we are measuring it
with 16 bits of precision like using a
16-bit number in there and that turns
this analog waveform that our ears can
detect
into a stream of numbers and we have a
stream of numbers brilliant we've turned
our little alert noise into a string of
numbers that we now want to be able to
replay on demand and that means we need
to be able to store those numbers
somewhere except there's a problem
because we haven't invented file systems
yet we haven't invented any way of
storing these bits yet now one of the
earliest data storage mechanisms before
we had the whole idea of transistors and
solid-state memory you take a piece of
pipe piece of glass tube and you'd fill
it up with mercury because hey why not
it's the 1950s and Uncle Sam is paying
and then you put a loudspeaker at one
end of it and you put a microphone at
the other end of it and you link the one
back into the other one and this is
delay line mercury tube memory this was
a real thing and it relied on the fact
that sound waves in mercury traveled
very very slowly so you can put a wave
into this thing and it'll take maybe
half a second to get to the other end
and when it gets to the other end you
can pick it up with a mic and send it
back round and retransmit it
and so by literally setting up a
standing wave in a glass column of
mercury you had a way of remembering a
digital signal one or zero
and coming back and reading it again
later which is something you know we all
take for granted you don't think of
having to invent this stuff but we did
and this is the delay memory from the
UNIVAC one it had 18 memory lines in
this unit each of them could store 120
bits univac one had ten of these units
there is some research that Alan Turing
did where he tried to see if you could
use gian instead of mercury to make
these things work but unfortunately
history does not record whether that was
successful or not
now this clearly wasn't gonna scale
terribly well you know mercury is
expensive and poisonous and dangerous
and all kinds of horrible we needed a
better system and somebody came up with
a bright idea what if we put little
magnetic particles on something like
tape or maybe a spinning disk and then
we can use an electromagnet to zap them
and flip them upside down and then
hopefully when we come back to read them
later they'll they'll still be flipped
and we invented originally magnetic tape
and then we invented mechanical hard
drives now we got phenomenally good at
building mechanical
drives what we've got here each of these
platters this has slowed down 50 times
it's from some guys on YouTube called
the slow mo guys and every single when
we read and write a file from a
mechanical disk what we are doing is we
are saying here are some metal discs
that are spinning at 15,000 revolutions
per minute there are a couple of hundred
million billion little tiny magnetic
particles on this disk we want you to go
to disk number four move to exactly this
position wait until the drive head
reaches this exact point in its rotation
and then just tell us what the bits are
on there that's the basic principle of
magnetic storage is a stream of magnetic
particles zeros and ones written onto
some physical medium and then on top of
that if you look at the file allocation
tables from the very earliest operating
systems we're talking like you know CPM
and ms-dos version one it's literally
here is a file name and it is at this
position on the physical disk and it is
this long that's what the file
allocation table is you know and we've
expended on it since then because we
invented things like symbolic links and
directories and folders and all kinds of
stuff but fundamentally the file
allocation table just said if you want
command comm you go to this location on
the physical disk and you read this many
bytes off it and that's that's the file
that you asked us to store there now
around the same time we're inventing
disks we were also inventing RAM memory
and memory is based on transistors which
are magic and the way a transistor
basically works it's an electronic
switch it's a little component that you
put current into one side and nothing
happens but if you feed in a signal into
what's called the base it effectively
opens the gate and it allows current to
flow through that device and you can
amplify it in the process as well and
someone came up with a bright idea if we
took one of these transistors and we
linked its output back into its own base
we effectively then have a device that
if you switch it on it'll stay switched
on and if you switch it off it'll stay
switched off and then we can use it to
store values we can use a store one or a
zero check this out we don't need any
mercury at all this is really cool and
someone else came along and said well
there's a slight problem with these you
know we can use them to build memory
banks if we want to store eight bits
brilliant
we'll feed all of them into the
collectors on all these transistors and
then we'll take that source signal away
and then we can come back later and we
can read out the values in all those
chips and bang there's our original
eight bits there's our bite back again
the problem with these is if the power
goes out they wipe you lose it sadface
this is not good you've lost I don't
know your homework your mp3s whatever
you had in that and somebody came along
and they said well I got a good idea
what if we could invent a transistor
that remembered whether you'd switched
it on or not even when the power's out
so we could we could put a signal in we
could switch it on we could take that
away and it would remember it it's state
and someone else said that is actually
impossible look we've proved it here
it's totally impossible and someone else
said yeah but check this out we're gonna
invent a thing called a floating gate
and the floating gate is gonna use weird
quantum stuff does anybody here have
small children haven't you ever
experienced the phenomenon where your
child has a little bit too much sugar
and you turn your back for a few seconds
when you turn back your child is in the
kitchen eating glue and the kitchen is
locked there is no way that your kid
could have got into the kitchen but
somehow while you were not observing
them they went into the sort of weird
quantum toddler hyper state and when you
turn back again they were somewhere
there's no way they could have been this
is exactly how solid-state memory works
we take a bunch of electrons and do what
is really only describable as weird
quantum stuff you put them into a
quantum state where their position can't
be determined and you rely on the fact
that when you read them back again some
of them will have got into this little
tiny device called a floating gate where
they will be stuck and once they're
stuck there we don't know how they got
there they don't know how they got there
but they stay there and you can come
back later and you can read the state of
that floating gate and see whether
there's electrons trapped in it or not
and in order to erase it all you do is
you push in a massive current through
the system and boom you get more weird
quantum stuff and the gates empty and it
gets erased so we've got this device
this quantum gate floating gate which is
impossible
according to the laws of conventional
physics how much do you think one of
these devices would cost you can get 64
billion of them from Amazon for 30 bucks
you know not only are we really good at
inventing this stuff we're really really
good at inventing it and then getting
brilliant at manufacturing it and
bringing the price of these things down
so literally when you buy a a memory
card for your camera or the memory
inside your phone you are talking about
billions of these physically impossible
quantum tunneling gate devices that we
use to store cat pictures and mp3 files
and stuff you know and as developers we
have all of this amazing magical
technology that we can go and play with
and do you know what the magic spell
that we have to use to access these
billions of magical quantum devices is
it's that because we're sitting on top
of this amazing pile of abstractions
that puts all of this power at our
fingertips so we can call file dot read
notify dot web and that will give us
back a stream of bits and then we can
turn those bits into a wave and then we
can turn that digital wave into an
analog wave and then we can push that
into this tiny little loudspeaker about
the size of a human fingernail and we're
getting a lot alert noise coming out the
other side and we get our phone and we
look at it and we go ah it's a cat
picture it's Lionel how did the picture
get there
so now I'm glad I'm doing this talk here
in Australia because it starts with this
yellow thing in the corner now over here
you know what that is when I did this
talk in the UK people like please what
is the yellow thing light comes out of
the Sun you're gonna have to trust me on
that one it just does it comes out of
the Sun it travels a couple of hundred
million miles across the empty void of
space and it hits Lionel right on his
little furry ginger face and some of it
bounces off the light that bounces off
is red and orange and white and it goes
through a lens and it hits this tiny
tiny little thing inside your phone
that's called a photo detector now the
brilliant thing about these photo
detectors very very simple device you
put light in one side you get
electricity comes out the back
the more light you put in the more like
electricity comes out but they can't see
colors they literally only see intensity
so somebody invented this thing which is
a as a engineer called Bryce Bayer
invented this grid of tiny little
colored glass crystals that basically
allows you to read all the cell's behind
it the things that are gray in this
diagram and by working out how much
light they're getting directly and how
much is coming from the adjoining cells
it can actually work out how much red
how much green how much blue is hitting
every one of the cells in this thing if
you got a 12 megapixel camera in your
phone which is pretty common these days
you're talking about 12 million of these
things inside a tiny tiny little thing
smaller than your fingernail on the back
your phone so we take this picture and
what we get out of it is we get a bitmap
literally a map of bits rows and columns
we get three of them we get one red one
green one blue we combine the three of
them we get at this picture of Lionel
now 12 megapixels times say we're
sampling each pixel at 8 bits so we can
go from 0 being completely dark to 255
being bright saturated it's gonna give
us 96 thousand thousand so 96 million
bits per channel which means this
picture of Lionel's gonna come out
around about 32 megabytes uncompressed
yeah which doesn't sound like a lot but
the wonderful thing about this tech is
that we can use it to send stuff all
over the world so we're all gonna get up
we're gonna get on a plane we're gonna
go here anyone know where this is this
is Bratislava the capital of Slovakia
and the reason why we're going to
Bratislava is actually there's two
reasons one of them is that if you are
going to Slovakia from Australia Roman
data is very very expensive you'll pay
three dollars for one megabyte and they
charge you by the kilobyte yeah which is
quite a lot so this picture we got here
of Lion or 32 Meg's we're gonna pay 96
bucks to look at that cat picture which
i think is a price worth paying but some
of you may not agree now the other
reason we're going to brothers love is
Rattus love has the cheaper
beer in the European Union a bottle of
local beer there is a baddy euro which
is about a buck sixty we convert it
which means this picture of lionel is
equivalent to this many bottles of
Slovakian beer now suddenly we have a
reason to see if we can make that
picture any smaller right because if we
can have the size the amount of data we
need to transmit that we get a whole lot
of beer to drink while we're sitting
there looking at our cap pictures so how
are we gonna compress this picture down
and get some beer money to spend on our
on our European vacation trip so we're
gonna start with the picture as I said
before when we capture that picture
using the camera in your phone you do it
on three channels red green blue and we
have this rule that on each channel zero
means black dark and 255 means as much
as you can get all the red all the green
all the blue that is not the only colour
model that works it's a color model that
works very well for digital cameras but
when it comes to image processing we're
gonna use a different system we're gonna
split it on three different channels
called y cbcr y it stems from the days
when this would be x and y on an
old-fashioned graph of time versus
intensity cbc our stand for crewman ins
blue and chrominance red and what we're
doing we're taking every little cell
every pixel in that picture of lionel
we're saying okay channel 1 how bright
is it channel 2 where is it on a sort of
scale of yellowness to blueness and
channel through you where is it on the
scale of redness to greenness and
there's a very very good reason we're
doing this which is to do it the way the
human eye perceives detail and color we
are really really good at seeing fine
detail in black and white we are not
good at seeing detail in color so we can
take this picture of Lionel we can split
it onto these three channels and then we
can throw away 75% of the information
from the color channels and we don't
notice your eye completely ignores this
because it's not that good at seeing
little details like claws and whiskers
and stuff in color anyway we're relying
on the black and white channel for all
of that fine detail so by doing that
we've instantly thrown away about 25-30
percent of the data that's encoded in
that they normally down so
by a factor of four when you're using
JPEG compression which is the the
algorithm we're talking about here so
we've saved a bunch of data now we are
gonna zoom in really really tight on
this picture and we're gonna cut Lionel
into little 8x8 pixel tiles this is
hypothetical by the way no cats were
harmed in the making of this there's
algorithm so we've broken this image
down each of these three channels we got
these tiny little 8x8 pixel tiles and
what we are gonna do now is we are gonna
work out for every one of these how we
can come up with a mathematical recipe
to recreate that tile now baked into the
JPEG compression standard there is this
thing this is a discrete cosine I'll get
back to your put that on Twitter later I
can't remember what it's called
basically what we've got here are all of
the possible 8x8 tiles that can be
expressed as a frequency basically and
we're gonna use these as ingredients in
a recipe and then we're gonna play
around with that recipe now I understand
over here and ahhs you you'd take your
burgers quite seriously so I looked up
this is a Ozzie burger with the lot this
is called and I started looking at this
and I'm thinking you know what could we
do how much could we compress this
recipe and still get a burger out at the
other end of it so we got this whole
list of ingredients here right we got
buns and mince and cheese and beet root
pineapple and all kind of stuff what
have we left out mayonnaise would that
still be a burger I think it probably
would what if you left out ketchup is it
still a burger mustard lettuce yeah now
there's gonna come a point what we're
doing here is we are tweaking the
threshold of our lossy compression we're
deciding how much information we are
comfortable living without yet where the
onion get rid of the pineapple get rid
of the beetroot too far okay
so we've hit the threshold there that
that's the point at which if we go any
further we're not gonna get a burger at
the other end of this recipe right but
by doing that we've achieved about 73%
data compression on this and JPEG works
exactly the same way these are our
ingredients now that white square up in
the top left corner
that's your minced beef that's important
we need a lot of that but the bottom
right corner these little kind of
checkerboard patterns that's the really
kind of fine detail that probably is not
that important so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna analyze each of these little
tiles in the spectra Lionel and we're
gonna decide we're going to throw away
the the condiments and the seasoning and
we're just gonna try and come up with a
really simple recipe for that tile we
analyze each of those tiles and we come
up with a matrix the matrix tells us how
much of each of these ingredients we
need to use to get that tile back at the
other end now there's a couple of things
about this that you'll notice first of
all the number in the top left in this
example is 53 that's really important
that's your you know your minced beef
and your patties you can't do without
that the numbers get smaller and as we
get towards the bottom right-hand corner
we get stuff that wasn't in the burger
to start with anyway like you know
lemonade and stuff there's no lemonade
in the cheeseburger so that's always
gonna come out as zero now this is the
really clever part what we're gonna do
now is we're gonna read out this series
of numbers and we're not gonna do it in
rows and columns we're gonna do it using
a pattern called the JPEG zigzag the
reason we do this one of the most
significant numbers the ones that are
really important they always come out
first so we can make our own decision as
to at what point do we stop and move on
to the next one the other thing we can
do is we can put a marker in that byte
stream which says okay you're good from
here on in the rest of the cell is just
zero skip ahead to the next tile skip
ahead to the next frame and that's how
JPEG compression works we throw away the
color information because our eyes can't
really see the fine detail anyway we
take what's left we turn it into tiny
slices we analyze each of those tiny
slices we come up with a mathematical
recipe for recreating it and then we
throw away the bits of that recipe that
we think we can live without and still
get back a passable approximation of
what we
and if you compress a JPEG really
heavily and then zoom right into it you
can actually see these individual tiles
and once you know what you're looking
for you'll see some of them are just
like a gradient fill we've thrown away
everything except this kind of very
gradual color shift from one to the
other because that's a recipe with only
one ingredient it says just give us
gradient for this that's fine
so we've compressed Lionel very heavily
he didn't really seem to mind he still
looks quite happy we got this we saved
ourselves a whole load of bandwidth we
can go out and spend the different Sun
beers but before we do that there are
rules this is the internet someone sends
you a cat picture you send back lul yeah
now you're thinking that's text how hard
can text be and a lot of the ideas we've
already talked about in this are about
we take something out of the real world
a photograph we turn that into data and
at the other end we want to be able to
turn it back into a photograph we take
some music or some audio we turn it into
data we get to the other end we want to
turn it back into something in the real
world take a piece of text turn it into
data turn it back into text how
difficult can this be and some people
are going yeah it's easy it's just plain
text and some people are going oh sweet
summer child let me tell you the stories
does anybody recognize this Morse code
anyone know what this says SOS does
anyone know what this says let me play
it to you SMS in order to send text as
digital information we need to agree an
encoding system between the sender and
the recipient we're gonna take something
that makes sense to us we're gonna turn
it into zero one zero one one zero one
zero the person on the other end needs
to know how to turn those ones and zeros
back into something meaningful now one
of the earliest
text encoding systems that was
successful because people could agree on
it was Morse code invented by Samuel
Morse and Morse codes incredibly
versatile you know you can use zeros and
ones instead of dots and dashes you can
use a flashlight you can use a telegraph
key there's all kinds of ways of sending
this code and it's successful because
the people on the other end
can recognize what it is and they can
decode it they can turn it back into
text now the problem with Morse code is
it's not actually terribly effective and
all the characters in it can be
different lengths so in the 1960s the
American computer thingy invented ASCII
the American Standard Code for
information interchange and you know
ASCII is kind of one of those things we
will take him for granted it seems kind
of weird that someone would sit down in
a world where ask you didn't exist and
they would invent it and when you start
digging into it you actually discover
they did some pretty clever stuff when
they come up with the way ASCII works so
one of the things we often come across
in software is someone says to us oh can
you give me these records in
alphabetical order and you go yeah and
then a little bit later in your career
you go do you want the capital letters
mixed in with the lowercase letters or
not you want a case sensitive or a case
insensitive sort and then even later in
your career you're like which of the 280
sequel server code pages would you like
me to use for alphabetical order you
know but one of the clever things about
ASCII is they effectively used one of so
ASCII was a seven bit code 0 through 127
and 0 through 31 they reserved for
control characters which literally used
to control things so carriage return
line feed the carriage return would move
the carriage and return it back to the
other side of the typewriter and the
line feed would feed the next line in
the printer and then for some reason
when we got Mac OS and Linux and windows
nobody could agree on which one of these
actually meant start the next line but
they used one bit of 7-bit ascii if you
want to sort an ASCII text file in
alphabetical order and you want it case
sensitive you just sort it numerically
if you want a case insensitive you just
ignore the sixth bit and you get a case
insensitive alphabetical sort out of it
now you know this worked fantastically
well for Americans who were reading and
writing text written in American English
because the people who invented it had
gone we'll what do we need in this code
all right we'll put all of those in it
that's fine we have a hundred twenty
seven characters now when I was about 10
years old I moved from Africa to the UK
and I was doing some homework on my 286
PC and I was writing something which had
how
signs in it this the the sterling
currency symbol and when I printed my
homework it came out as this and I had
my first experience of character
encodings because what we had done
throughout the 70s and the 80s and the
90s is we'd said all right well American
ascii is 0 327 so we'll take the other
half the 128 through 255 and in the UK
we used it to do one thing and in
Western Europe they used it to do
something else and in places all over
the world they had what they call code
pages these are a different set of
standards where you agree on what those
extended ASCII characters mean and the
problem with code pages is there was no
way within a file of saying what coach
code page you should use for it you had
to know in advance using another channel
now you know what tell me what this says
privyet hi in russian and russia of
course does not use any approximation of
the Western alphabet Russian uses the
Cyrillic alphabet so when they started
building computers in Russia that were
doing text encoding the international
standards organization very helpfully
said here you go Russia here is a text
encoding system that you can use now
this is in the days when 7-bit ascii was
so common that a lot of devices could
not cope with the 8th bit they would
literally strip it off in transit you
know there were email systems that would
strip the 8-bit off any attached text
file there were Network protocols which
would drop the 8-bit because they used
it for their own purposes so when
somebody wrote the word privyet in
Russian and they encoded it and that bit
got chopped off by 7-bit encoding
devices and they tried to put it back
together at the other end they would get
gibberish so some Russian scientists
when we don't think the Americans have
really appreciated the nuance of our
alphabet here we have a much better idea
so they came up with something called
the K oh I ate the code ordinate in
formats key encoding and what they did
was they said instead of using Russian
alphabetical order we're going to encode
it based on which American which English
letter is the closest in terms of
pronunciation
so you take the word pretty yet you run
it through this thing that 8-bit gets
chopped off by all these stupid devices
but when you put it back together at the
other end what you get out of it is
something which kind of approximates
what went into it they flipped the upper
and the lower case on purpose to make it
obvious that this thing had been mangled
in transmission but they mangled it in
such a way that it was still readable
when it came out the other side which i
think is is really really clever and
there is before we get on to how we
solve this problem there is a really
weird historical footnote about all of
these different encoding systems in 1987
Billy Joel played a concert in Leningrad
which is now some Petersburg which was
released on vinyl and cassette in the
Soviet Union and because it was only
released in the Soviet Union the title
of the album is concert written on the
cover in Russian and then at some point
someone took the the Sony music database
and had to start putting it into
computer systems and they looked at this
word on the cover of this album and they
went Co who kept Co who apt and if you
go on iTunes today and such for Co who
eped
live in Leningrad it's a real album it's
on Spotify it's on iTunes it's on Google
Play all because of this little encoding
glitch from the 1980s that everyone
thought we had solved because no one has
come up with a way of kind of
retrospectively going in and fixing this
stuff and even if they could you know if
they gave it the right name you wouldn't
be able to search for it because you
don't have those keys on your keyboard
so historical footnotes aside enter the
Unicode consortium who were like we
should sort this whole messy business
with the code pages and stuff at once
and for all you know let's actually fix
this problem and what the Unicode
consortium did they actually only solved
half the problem because what they said
they were going to do we want to give a
unique code a unique code point to every
character in every alphabet that is or
has ever been used by humans so they
came up with a couple of ideas first of
all they're like from 0 to 127 we'll do
the same as ASCII and I'll talk in a
second about why this was a
and brilliant solution and then they
just went well we've got all the space
to play with you know we've got
theoretically unlimited number of code
points let's just start dropping
alphabets into them and given them all
code points so we have distinct code
points for English and Russian and Greek
and playing card characters we even if
you really really want to compress data
and send stuff around the world quickly
the best thing you can possibly do is to
agree in advance a code point for the
thing you want to send does anyone know
what this is I'll be amazed if you do
this is domestic cat facing left
this is the ultra compressed version of
Lionel it's one Unicode code point now
the Unicode consortium said here you go
we've given numbers to all the letters
in all the alphabets it's your problem
now engineers you go and fix the rest
and everyone went okay how hard can that
be so we've got let's say we're gonna
use four bytes so we're gonna use 32
bits of space to encode all of the
characters in our text file and the
first character you see is a and you go
well obviously you know a the the ASCII
code for that 65 and Unicode uses the
same as ASCII for that so a will be this
and then the old dude in the back with
the beard who remembers how C and C++
work goes son I see a problem with your
text file here because there's a lot of
software out there which cannot cope
with a byte that is all zeroes do they
want to tell me why it's a null
termination character in C and in C++
and in languages influenced by them in
the way they handle strings and so an
awful lot of the utilities and
applications that exist on most modern
command-line systems just are not
designed to cope with a text file text
file which has a string of eight zeros
in it anywhere so they had a bit of a
thing and they came up with what I think
is a really really clever solution to it
they came up with utf-8 encoding now the
brilliant thing about utf-8 UCF file
xand ASCII files are interchangeable
because every ASCII file that only uses
seven bits of ASCII is
so a completely valid utf-8 file and
it's exactly the same so all the files
that already exist we can keep using
them they then come up with the idea
okay so we've got this the eighth bit
the bit that kept throwing people off
the mark back in the day let's use that
as an indicator that this byte is part
of a utf-8 byte sequence and they said
if it starts with a 1-1 that means this
is the beginning of a multi byte string
and if it starts with a one zero it
means it's a continuation character go
back to the previous one that's the
beginning and then read forwards from
there and the brilliant thing about this
and then the rest of it the bits which
are red Xs in here that is the number
that is the numeric value that you're
working with and this expands if you see
one one it means this is two bytes long
if you see one one one it means this is
the start of a three byte sequence if
you see one one one one means this is
the start of a four byte sequence this
gives us enough address space to go up
to theoretically eight bytes which is
256 bits which is a phenomenal amount of
storage that's enough for all the human
alphabets all the historical human
alphabets all the fictional human
alphabets and all the alphabets were
going to have to deal with when we make
contact with Alpha Centauri and start
trying to send email to other star
systems and we've still got enough space
left over to invent emoji and cats and
hearts and smiling faces and bees and
always in little random characters that
people can now use to send messages to
each other around the world and you know
the fantastic thing about all of this
all this complexity all of these
solutions all this technology is you
know we as software developers we can
use it with that having to understand
all the details of how it works there
was this great xkcd strip a couple of
months back which opens with someone
saying you know I I had this app and I
had a calendar webpage and I wanted to
show them side-by-side but the operating
system didn't have split-screen support
so I decided to build my own app and
then I realized it would be easier to
get two small phones on eBay and glue
them together and on that day I achieved
software enlightenment and then the last
frame that guiana hats but you never
learned to write software and they said
no I just learned how to glue together
stuff that I don't understand
fair enough now that's important because
that's what we do that's that's how we
do it that's what all of us are doing
now when we build software applications
there's nobody left in the world who
wants the kind of applications that are
built by someone who understands the
registers and the processes there was a
day probably in the 1980s when you could
literally put a computer together by
soldering components and then write
games on it that was so good your
friends would come over and want to play
on them but you know the stakes are so
much higher we can do so much more now
the people who invented JPEG compression
and the people who invented 4G cellular
networking they didn't do it so that you
could send cap Nick just to someone on a
train they did it because they were like
if we can solve this problem and we can
put the solution out there other people
will use it to create cool things let's
build it and put it out in the world and
see what they can do and the reason why
you know we do this the reason this
stuff works is most of the time these
solutions work really really well they
work so well we take them for granted
they're ubiquitous
and it's only when you get your phone
out and you can't get any signal that
you even stop to think for maybe a
fraction of a second and on maybe this
was actually maybe there's quite a lot
going on here that normally we take for
granted over the next three days you're
going to have a chance to talk to each
other to talk to the speakers to talk to
the sponsors talk to the organisers all
the people who are here are here because
we want to build cool stuff we want to
glue together things that maybe we
understand maybe we don't understand and
we want to build interesting
applications and create great user
experiences and solve problems do all
this kind of stuff and one of the
reasons that these conferences like NDC
are so fantastic is because you can have
those kind of conversations face to face
now I want to give you one tip how many
of you here is your first time it is
anyone here so first time at any
conference ever okay that's cool we got
a couple how many is your first time
here at NDC and Sydney all right awesome
very glad you're all here there is a
thing Eric
as pacman rule sky Aric culture came up
this I think this is a brilliant rule
it's a bat away of being friendly and a
way of encouraging conversations if you
find yourself you know out there or
maybe in the bar at the party and
there's a couple you've stood round in a
circle or there is this very easy human
thing if you arrive somewhere at 10
o'clock in the morning you assume the
people who were there at nine o'clock
are all lifelong friends and they know
each other and you're a stranger and so
you feel like you're interjecting and it
feels rude kind of going up to people
and going hey can I join your
conversation so there's a very easy rule
if you find you're in a circle and
you're talking about angular or react or
progressive algorithms or or whatever
somebody comes up they won't be able to
join your group
so remember pact now if you're standing
in a circle leave a space it's really
easy and then somebody else can come up
and they can join in and as soon as they
join of course you move that you make
another gap just this one little simple
thing can make the whole experience of
meeting people exchanging ideas you know
swapping war stories about that horrible
thing that you all had with entity
framework all that stuff go so so much
easier so now that we've dug into the
technology I just want you to watch this
clip one more time and think about
what's really going on here now
you
thank you very much
Thank You Dylan once again give it up
for Dylan bTW everyone
thank you so what do you give a guy with
a hundred hats another hat ah that's
beautiful so yeah this is the third and
this is City we're doing but there's
actually our fourth conference here in
Australia we've done a security
conference on the Gold Coast before so
who's been to all four conferences in
Australia from NDC oh there's a hands
what's your name sir that's Troy hyung
that's then you get to speak thank you
have you met him in this room that's
Troy handoff to this thank you all for
coming guys have a good conference and
we'll see you around and all the people
who bet me a beer I couldn't talk about
one cat picture for an hour I'll be in
the bar thanks a lot have a great
conference
[Applause]